[Music]  the future mr. and mrs. Bieber enjoy a  romantic date night in NYC I'm having a  good time from the Bahamas to Brooklyn  Haley Baldwin can't get enough of fiance  Justin Bieber since he popped the big  question he's just really sweet he's a  good kid it's a good heart and I love  him check out the newly engaged couple  walking hand-in-hand with their love and  Haley's bling on full display Bieber and  Baldwin went casual for their summer  date night the 21 year old models  sporting black and white at leisure wear  which flashed her toned abs while the  pop star stayed close by his bride-to-be  in a fitted cap blue hoodie sweatpants  and sneakers a source tells et Stephen  Baldwin's daughter is over the moon with  joy about their engagement and we see  why with that huge rock as her latest  accessories  you  [Music]